Everything I do is directed towards
getting more meaning out of the content.
Are there Steve Kaufmann here.
Today I want to talk about
flashcards and learning vocabulary.
Uh, remember if you enjoy these
videos, please subscribe, click
on the bell for notifications.
And um, if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a commentary.
I do appreciate it.
So I'm often asked to sort of
show how I learn, what do I do?
How do I study?
And I've often said that learning
vocabulary is, is the key.
It's my number one goal:
increase my known words total.
So how do I go about doing it?
What is the role of flashcards
in my program of study?
What is the role of, uh, you
know, spaced repetition systems?
So I'm going to demonstrate.
I do most of my studying on my iPad.
Some people do it on the, uh,
you know, on their computers.
Some people use LingQ on
their iPhone or Android.
I do it on a tablet.
I do it on my iPad.
So I'm going to show you that a little
later, but first a couple of principles.
First of all, I believe that when we learn
words, we learn them within a holistic
sort of the whole language, it's part of
our becoming familiar with the language.
The individual vocabulary items
are connected to the language.
In a way they are not discreet.
Now here's a word for those of you
who are non-native speakers, as
you know discreet D I S C R E E T
means to be, uh, you know, not to
be too obvious in what you're doing.
Uh, that's discreet, you know, not to
embarrass people or whatever, that's
discreet in that sense, but discrete, D I
S C R E T E means that it's not connected.
It's separate.
So vocabulary items are not discrete.
They are connected.
It's part of that holistic
getting used to the language.
Until you are comfortable and
familiar with the language the
vocabulary items are not gonna stick.
Or they'll stick for awhile
and then you'll forget them.
So that's the second point
about vocabulary items.
You're going to learn
them and forget them.
And if you leave the language for awhile,
you're going to forget more of them, but
that's not a problem because once you
have learned them and then you go back in
there and you relearn them and rediscover
them or find them again, you do strengthen
your hold on those, because you see them
in more and more in different contexts.
So it's important to learn
vocabulary in a meaningful content.
So, uh, that's the third thing
about how I learned vocabulary.
I, to the extent that I review
vocabulary items and I'll show you
that I do this more in lists than in
flashcards, I do it connected to content.
So you'll see when I demonstrate that,
uh, every lesson that I'm in at LingQ,
every content item, I will review the
vocabulary that's connected to that
content item, because basically what I
want to do is get through the content
item, get through that item that I'm
studying and I'm looking at words and
listening to it's to, and where I listen
several times and still don't understand
the same parts or I look up words.
And when I hear them, I can't
remember what they mean.
And, and so it's all, uh, everything I do
is directed towards getting more meaning
out of the content without having to think
about it without having to translate.
And so my review of vocabulary
is specific most of the time is
specific to the content that I'm
studying, but there are exceptions.
I like to feel good about
my language learning.
And so I like to see more known words.
And so, because typically I have
created a lot of LingQs, some of
them I moved to status two, in other
words, I'm a little more familiar
or status three, even more familiar.
And I like to move them to known.
So I will, and I'll demonstrate this as
well, I will go into my vocabulary section
and then isolate the status three words
that I'm close to feeling I know, and I'll
go in there and I'll move them to known.
I move them to known, but I realize
that many of the words that I
moved to known will slide to
status three or even status too.
It doesn't bother me.
I accept the fact that I'm going
to learn and forget and relearn.
And the final thing I would say about
my approach to vocabulary acquisition,
and use of flashcards and lists.
And you'll see that I use lists
more than flashcards is that
to me, reviewing vocabulary is
just another form of exposure.
Uh, I don't believe that if I review
uh, you know, a bunch of items in an SRS
system, spaced repetition system that I'll
get some kind of a permanent hold on them.
I still need them within a
lot of meaningful content.
Uh, also, I don't believe...
I'm not a fan of flashcards because I
don't believe the time that I spend at
racking my brain trying to remember uh,
you know, if I see a word in, in either
in my language or in the target language,
and I have to remember what that means,
racking my brain to try and do that.
I don't find that useful.
I've never found that useful.
So I go through the list as
another form of exposure.
Uh, ultimately the language has got
to come in to your brain through
exposure, reading content, listening
to content or reviewing lists are
all different forms of exposure.
Uh, so I don't like to rack
my brain using flashcards.
So with that as an introduction, let me
demonstrate how I do this on my iPad.
And I'll come back and talk to you again.
So, um, I'm going to try to show
you how I deal with vocabulary.
I'm going to look at Turkish because I
studied Turkish a few years ago now, and
I've forgotten a lot of it, but I always
feel whatever effort I've put into it.
When I go back in and
relearn it, I know it better.
So that doesn't bother me.
So there's a number of different items in
our, in our, um, you know, library here.
But I'm gonna to go to this one here,
Baja Stories, very good series in Turkish.
And if you'll see the green line in some
of these stories, that indicates that
I've been through it once when I was
working hard on my Turkish and the gray
line here indicates I haven't started on.
Um, so we could look at it doesn't
really matter, but if we look at
this, uh, uh, ... I must admit, I
don't understand what that is anymore.
I haven't done this before.
It has 74 unknown words, 93, uh, words
that I've looked up 24% unknown words.
Let's Open it up and see what happens.
... by region.
Okay ... I don't know, use of,
ah, ... use of, so, um, okay.
I need that.
So I convert my, because that phrase
doesn't make a lot of sense to me.
Usage of Turkish by region.
Oh ...usage of Turkish by region.
So I'll also save that as a phrase.
...is roughly, I remember that.
...so
... country.
Big country.
So normally if I were to go back into my
Turkish, I would go through this whole
lesson and I would look up ... naturally.
Okay.
Even if I kind of think maybe I
know what ... they speak spoken.
Okay.
I look them all up
anyway, ... from the region.
Okay.
... changes.
So a lot of these things, I would be
refreshing things that I had once learned
and have now forgotten and going through
this reading and again, and going, looking
up the yellow words again, it's all
helping me re uh, Uh, remember ... the
Turkish different  in different in areas.
Okay.
And, uh, so normally if I were doing this,
I would go through and I would look up
all the yellow words and I would read it.
I'm now in a review stage, but of
course it's a new lesson so there's
also words I haven't seen before.
... I don't know.
I guess that's the...
okay.
So just for the sake of this video,
I'll just go and hit the blue words.
...
talking that, I actually knew that.
... in the Southeast.
accent.
All right.
So normally then having gone through
this page, it's now review time.
So the options for me are
I can review the page.
There's 56 flashcards.
Okay.
So I could learn them.
Uh, okay.
So this is like hearing...
making sure I understand what I hear.
Uh, but I don't do flashcards.
I could, it's sometimes fun to do
them, but I tend not to do them.
I also have 110, ... is that?
... yeah, incorrect.
First of all.
So, but I, then I don't do
flashcards because I just don't
find racking my brain that useful,
but there's different exercises in
the flashcards there's cloze tests.
Uh, but I'm not going
to try and attempt this.
Cause what I do is I simply go to my
list typically now, because I've been
away from this for so long, there's a
huge list of words just from this lesson,
because it was quite a long lesson.
So I'm not going to go through this list.
It's too much.
If I'm going to review these words, I'll
review them page by page, in the actual
text, in the actual text, reading it a
second time, looking up a second time.
However, one thing that can be
useful to do, which I often do as
a nother it's a sort of variety.
I go to my vocabulary section and familiar
over here means that I have chosen
to only look at status three words.
Those are words that I've seen
several times and therefore
I've moved them to status three.
And you'll notice here in the "sort by" I
tend to work with the alphabetical order.
And there's a reason for that.
And that is that typically
you'll have common prefix so
words that begin A B A R T
...
there are exaggerators.
... all means something to
do with, um, exagerate.
... open air ... frankly
... open ... So ... means open.
So you start to see
relationships between words.
So again, for me, vocabulary
review is a form of exposure.
I'm not testing myself the way
flashcards tend to test you.
I also wanted to show you something.
Uh, since we have added new languages,
if I go to say, because it's too
difficult to do, and in Armenian, I can't
even read Armenian, but in Icelandic,
I had a quick look there and, um,
...so I have already listened to these
first two sentences and I've sort of, some
of the words are so similar to Swedish
that I don't even need to save them.
Uh, but there'll be a lot of blue words.
... is he same as Swedish.
... lives, but that doesn't mean it might
mean lives, but ... means makes so very
often the phrase has a different meaning.
... is going to be breakfast.
That's very easy.
... is and.
... drinks, coffee, coffee.
So as I come across words, ...drives.
Okay.
... well, whatever ... okay.
That's a word that's completely
different from Swedish.
And so I would typically go through here
converting the blue words to yellow.
And then I, as I did before I
would go, if I click on this, I
can see my vocabulary lists here.
They won't be as many because
it's a much shorter lesson here.
It would be helpful to go through this.
I could also, sorry, look up all the
new words ahead of time if I wanted
to review them before starting.
But again, I don't find that quite as
useful as reviewing them in the actual
lesson text over time as the number of
blue words disappear as blue or disappear
and there's fewer and fewer yellow.
I then find it useful to look at my list
as a quick way of reviewing the lesson,
uh, that I've been away from for a while.
So I hope that quick,
uh, overview is useful.
Uh, again, I'm happy to do this again.
If you let me know what you would
like to see me do on my iPad.
Well, I hope that was useful.
Um, maybe I think some
things are confusing.
I'd be happy to clarify.
Uh, if there are other aspects
of how I study and how I learn
languages, that you would like me
to demonstrate, please let me know.
At any rate, uh, there you have a
peek into how I study vocabulary.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.